you know the choice is to stripe
yourself to a rocket ship or to build
your own you know mr elon built his own
literally with the rocket ship
that's a difficult choice because um
there's a world
actually i would say something different
which is elon and others decided to sell
paypal
for
not that much i mean how much was it
about a billion dollars i can't remember
something like that yeah i mean it was
early and um but it's worth a lot more
now than building new rocket ships so
this is the cool part right if you are
an entrepreneur and you own a
controlling stake in the company
not only is it really hard to do
something else with your life because
all of the
you know value is tied up in you as a
personality attached to this company
right
but if you sell it and you get yourself
enough capital and you like have enough
energy
you could do another thing or 10 other
things or in elon's case like a bunch of
other things i don't know like i lost
count at this point um
and it might have seemed silly at the
time and sure like if you look back man
paypal's worth a lot now right
but i don't know like do you think elon
like cares about like are we gonna buy
pinterest or not like i just he is
he created a a a massive capital that
allowed him to do what he wants to do
and that's awesome that's more freeing
than anything because when you are an
entrepreneur attached to a company you
gotta stay at that company for a really
long time it's really hard to remove
yourself but i'm not sure how much he
loved paypal versus spacex and tesla
i have a sense that you love
instagram
yeah i loved enough to like
work for six years beyond the which is
rare which is very rare you chose but
can i tell you why sure it's um
please
there are not a lot of companies that
you can be part of where
the pope's like i would like to sign up
for your product like i'm not a
religious person at all
i'm really not um yeah but when you go
to the vatican and you're like walking
among the giant columns and you're
hearing the music and everything and
like the pope walks in and he wants to
press the sign up button on your product
like it's a moment in life okay um no
matter what your persuasion okay
the number of doors and experiences that
that opened up was it was incredible i
mean the people i got to meet the places
i got to go
um i assume maybe like a payments
company is slightly different right
but that's why like it was so fun and
plus i truly believed we were building
such a great product and i loved loved
the game it wasn't about money it was
about the game
you